we're now going to look at another
matrix that comes up very frequently
it's the incidence matrix associated
with a graph
so this comes up in a ton of fields so
we'll look at the basics now so
basically we have a graph a graph is
something you should know about you
probably have an intuitive idea of what
a graph is but i'll say it a little bit
more formally
if you've taken some computer science
you may have seen this in a more formal
setting or maybe a math class or some
other class where you've already seen
this
for example electrical engineering where
you'd use a you'd use a graph to
represent a circuit
um anyway so here it is a graph we're
going to consider a graph with n
vertices so i've drawn one down here
and it'll give you a rough eye so this
is just a baby example
this has got four vertices and the
vertices are usually drawn as like
circle
or dots or something like that so here
it's got four
vertices some people use other names for
vertices like
nodes is another common name used for a
vertex of a graph
and then there are also edges now an
edge is an
arrow and it's oriented so it goes from
one
node to another or from one vertex to
another so
for example that's an edge and here
we're drawing then they're typically
drawn
as uh arrows um and the the arrow of
course
tells you where it goes from and two so
for example
this is an edge that goes from vertex
one
to vertex two and we're actually calling
it
edge number one in this case okay and so
we have
n vertices and we have m uh
edges oh other names for edges are links
is one
edge link um there's probably a couple
of other names for it depending on the
field
maybe branch in electrical engineering
is another name for it so
a bunch of people have different uh
different names uh for
for a different nomenclature for a graph
okay now associated with this graph one
very one very common way to describe a
graph is by
its incidence matrix and
um so this is a matrix it's it's n by m
so it's the number of vertices that's
the number of rows and the number of
columns is the number
of edges and it's defined this way
it's a i j is equal to uh it's
one if edge j remember the second index
is going to index the edges or the links
and the first index i is going to index
the nodes
so or the nodes or the vertices so it's
plus one if edge j
points into node i and
it's minus one if edge j points
out of node i and zero otherwise so
what that tells you is a column which
consists of a fixed value of
j and all i's a column corresponds
the jth column tells you about the j
edge
and of course an edge only it goes from
one node
to another node and that tells you that
every column of this matrix
has exactly one plus one and one minus
one
all the other entries are zero okay so
that's that's what this uh looks like
um so here is an example of a graph
and here is the corresponding uh
incidence matrix for that graph
so let's take a look at what uh what we
see here let's audit it
uh well let's take edge one okay so edge
number one
goes from vertex one to vertex
two so and then remember ver
edge one is associated with the first
column of a and so here's the first
column of a
and you see sure enough uh this says
it goes to node two that's why there's a
plus one here
minus one says it comes out of node one
and that's why there's a minus one
and it is doesn't have anything to do
with node three or node four that's what
these zeros mean here
um and i think the fancy way to say it
is you would say that
edge one is not incident to
you know vertices three or four that's
why there's zeros there
um and so let's we can actually uh i
could ask some questions uh for example
we've already discussed that the
columns of an incidence matrix
correspond each one each column
describes one edge or link
in in the uh in the graph and it'll have
a plus one and a minus one period
um now the rows are more interesting
let's take like the third row and let's
ask ourselves what does it mean
well the third row is associated with
node three
that's over here and what it says
is it now if you go along that row it
tells you
whether or not that edge is either
coming in into that node or going out of
that node
or or doesn't even touch that node is
not incident to that node and so for
example
if we go across the third row we see
zero zero and that means that edges
one and two don't have anything to do
with node three and that's true here's
node one here's
sorry edge one and here's edge two and
you can see that they
they go between one and two and one and
four and have absolutely nothing to do
with node three so those are correct
then you get a plus one and that says
that
this is this tells you that edge three
is
points into node three and indeed that's
the case you can see this
um it also says that so in other words a
plus one
indicates that that edge is incoming
um the minus one in four and five says
that that edges four and five go out of
node three and let's check that and sure
enough that's right so these are
outgoing
edges right so that that's an example so
so again the columns tell you about a
single
edge um and it tells you well very
little it tells you
where the edge comes from and where it
goes and a row tells you
focuses on a node and it tells you which
of the edges are coming in
which are going at which you're incoming
which are outgoing and which have
nothing to do with that node
okay so that's a that's a graph now
these come up in a ton of
applications i'll i'll say a little bit
about we'll probably see some later in
the class as well
okay so very common uh
is this is um we imagine that the
m-vector x
is going to give you the flows of
something
along an edge right so graphs often tell
you in that case by the way in that case
a graph might be called a network
right like a transportation network or
something like that
or a well an energy or power
network so usually you can interpret
what flows along the edges is something
like it could be heat
it could be money it could be power as
in an electricity
distribution system it could be mass
literally masses flowing from one
process
to another or it could be people and the
nodes could be locations and an edge
tells you that
people are moving from one location to
another
okay now in this case
it depends in many cases uh so here
x there's a common uh unit a universal
um convention is this is when you're
talking about the flow
when x is positive x sub j is positive
it means that the flow follows the edge
direction
if it's negative it simply means that
the flow
of people mass money whatever it is
you're you're
keeping track of goes the opposite
direction as the edge the opposite
orientation
so that's the idea of of of of a
that's sometimes called a network um
okay
now when you do ax something super
interesting happens
um it it takes a flow so x is a flow
vector it's a vector flows on the edges
and if you go back and think about what
it means to multiply by x so if these
are the flows
like here's x1 you know down to
x5 here then
if you look at one of these i mean here
we could just let's let's audit the
bottom one
so what's going to happen is ax is going
to be
x2 plus x5
okay they're both positive okay i'm just
telling you that this is what
ax the fourth entry of x is now that
fourth entry
is associated with the vertex so let's
look over here
and sure enough look at that what it
tells you is that if
if x1 x2 x3 x4 x5 are the flow of
something on each of these edges
then x2 plus x5 that's the that's the
total
flowing into node four um let's look
at node two that's this thing
and you can see if i multiply this out i
get x1 minus
x3 and so let's look at node 2. here it
is
and what we see is that x1 is the
incoming flow on edge 1. x3
is the outgoing flow on edge 3
and you see in fact it's the net flow uh
for
node two in other words it's the it's
the algebraic net like you know
one unit is coming in or x1 units are
coming in x3 are going out and you
subtract them
and that's kind of the net amount that's
flowing into
node two so that's the idea that's
that's what matrix vector multiplication
does when you have an incidence matrix
it converts a flow into the
net flows at all of the nodes um so
that's that's the
idea now a very special equation is ax
equals zero um and that's called uh
flow conservation um and in that case if
if x satisfies that it's called a
circulation
right and that's super interesting
because what it means is flow
conservation
says that the totally the net amount
flow the total amount the net amount
flowing in the node is zero and that
means that the total amount flowing in
on incoming edges exactly balances the
total
the total flow going out of the node on
outgoing edges so that that's flow
conservation
so if this was an electrical circuit you
would say
this would be called like kirchhoff
current law and it basically says
that all the current coming into that
node
go and you know balances exactly all the
current going out of it so that's that's
that's the context in which it comes up
and it's called the circulation
um so as a matter of fact let's just
make ourselves a circulation for this
graph
so a circulation could be
something that looks like this i'll just
visualize one here's a circulation
i'm going to draw it it's going to go
like that and that okay
so a circulation says that you have a
flow going from node two to node three
uh another flow going from three to one
and a flow going from one to two and you
can see that it circulates and so that
would correspond exactly to
x equals and let's let's try to get it
right
so it's first on edge one so and it's a
one
edge two is zero edge three
is one and four is
one and five is zero so that is a that
is a circulation and you can check
with that vector that ax is in fact zero
okay so this is the idea um and this
this in different in different areas
it's going to have different specialized
names
uh i already mentioned one in circuits
this is called
kirchhoff current law and it says okay
it's the obvious one
okay now with graphs uh there's a
there's something that involves the
transpose of
the incidence matrix and it's actually
very interesting we'd focus before
x was a vector that gave you flows on
the edges
but now what we're going to do that was
an m vector now we're going to look at n
vector and we're going to call it v and
it's going to be we're going to call it
a potential
because that's what it's called in many
fields mostly comes from physics
mechanics these kinds of things
or electrical engineering also okay so
you have an n vector and what an n
vector is is it tells you
it's a gives you a number on each of the
nodes of your graph
right so it says well it's 12.6 there
it's minus 11 there it's 2 you know that
kind of thing so every
every node on your graph has a number
and we think of it as a potential okay
now here what is very interesting is if
you multiply by the transpose
of the uh of the incidence matrix you
get something super interesting
let's go back to an incidence matrix
here let's begin we've messed it up
quite a bit
uh but if you transpose this in your
mind the rows of a transpose are these
these vectors that are each row is
associated with an
edge and it tells you it's got exactly
one one and one minus one and in fact if
you
multiply such a vector uh
by if you multiply sorry such if you
have the inner product of that vector
with another vector
what you're doing is you're taking the
difference of two entries so
it turns out the following is what
happens
it turns out that
a transpose v is super interesting
what it is is it's an m vector of the
potential
differences across the m edges right so
again in electrical engineering you
would you could think of the
this could be a circuit the graph could
represent a circuit and
v could represent the voltage at
each node then when you form a transpose
v what you're getting is a vector which
is the length of the edges and it tells
you the voltage difference
across each of the edges okay
so that's the idea now something else
related
to potentials is something called the
dirichlet energy
and that'll also come up uh it's super
interesting it's this
what it is is it is the norm
squared of a transpose
v v is a potential a vector of
potentials
and so as you know a transpose v gives
you a vector now
associated uh with the edges
each each component of a transpose v is
corresponds to an edge and it gives you
the difference in the potential across
that edge
okay and if you take the sum of the
squares of them that gives you the
so-called
dirichlet energy and so here's one way
to write that
this says that you only sum uh you sum
over the edges on
on the graph so whenever two nodes are
adjacent
i didn't say that but when two nodes are
connected by an edge
you would say that they are uh adjacent
um
so this says that uh you'd sum over the
potential differences
okay and uh right now there's no
application of this but we'll see it
later
you should think of the dirichlet energy
as an interesting thing
it is zero when the potential or the
vector v
is constant in other words it's a
multiple of the ones vector
why because in that case all of these
are zero because every entry of the
vector's the same
you subtract them you get zero and you
sum and square them you get zero
otherwise what this is is it's a it's
something that measures uh
i'll say very roughly how wiggly your
potential v is
across the graph right it it penalizes
uh potential differences that are large
uh across an edge okay so you would say
if if
if d of v is small you would say that
the potential v
is smoothly varying over the graph okay
i just mentioned these ideas we're going
to see more of this later but that's the
idea
you